it's tough five times so i'll bring you
a rhyme we can talk about game news but
we don't have much time let's cover to
have some consoles right up to the end
but there's one thing I promise I won't
do this again and the melodramatic dev
of the Week award ghosty Ubisoft's Colin
Graham who said that the PS Wars nia
unlimited memory gave them a chance to
dream although it's another pretty good
sunset quote the watchdog's animation
director has implied that the praise is
totally warranted since they've been
able to reduce animation compression and
add variety to citizens thanks to the
lack of limitations using the ps4 gram
compared it to working with an unlimited
budget and while I have taken to making
fun of him I totally respect the
excitement from his perspective Nvidia
also blew everybody's hardware mind
holes this week by announcing the three
thousand dollar GTX Titan said graphics
card while it's pretty much completely
out of everybody's price range the sweet
card is powered by 5760 processing cores
and includes two gk110 chips it's built
around to Kepler GPUs and 12 gigabytes
of dedicated frame buffer memory Nvidia
say it's super powered and quiet
unfortunately that doesn't make three
grand appear in my wallet next up Sony
published a list of 100 games that are
coming to the ps4 in 2014 so now you'll
finally have something to play on next
gen hear that joke never gets old you
can check out the full list on gamespot
but it includes recent releases like
metal gear solid ground zeroes as well
as anticipated titles including destiny
and the brand new Assassin's Creed unity
the release dates are subject to change
but as of right now you can expect them
to land this year speaking of Assassin's
Creed unity it is all prepped to come to
pc xbox one and ps4 in the holiday
season of this year it's going to be set
during the 18th century during the
French Revolution now that we can rest
easy knowing where the thing is taking
place you be have said that a spin in
development for three years
no word on if unity will get a wii u
version but the trailer is full of
lovely scenic paris shots and a dramatic
guillotine so we can only ask for so
much let me know if you are expecting
the french revolution or the something
different and to nobody's great surprise
the biggest story of the week and the
first story in a very long time to bring
outcry from gamers jonas and dev alike
was that facebook has bought oculus yeah
so that companies still sitting
comfortably in the running for worst
company in America on the consumerist
after even EA was knocked out now owns
the oculus rift after a two billion
dollar buyout on the whole you guys are
less than pleased although there's been
nothing to suggest that Facebook will
trade out hardcore gaming experiences
for virtual farm bill apprehension from
gamers and those who elected to back the
original oculus rift project on
Kickstarter is pretty understandable let
me know if you are angry about the
acquisition or if you still have faith
in oculus you can drop all your thoughts
feelings hopes and dreams in that
commenting section down below what you
can do so on my twitter where i'm at
jeff mcdonald this week on site i took a
break from playing Reaper of souls to
make a video about why it's so much
better than diablo vanilla sub made a
phenomenal final episode on half-life 3
for the waiting game and Danny tells you
about what he can get done in under 60
minutes on the point and those are all
the things worth knowing about from
gaming this week but be sure to catch me
again on Monday but till then have a
wonderful weekend
speaking of Assassin's Creed unity it is
all prepped to come to pc xbox one and
ps4 in the holiday season and it's going
to be set in the 18th century during the
French Revolution